one of the best definitions of
serendipity is when you look for
something and then you find something
else and you realize that what you found
was more conducive to your needs than
what you thought you were looking for
right so synchronicity by definition is
when the right thing just shows up right
when the lesson you needed to learn is
finally resolved it's finally made clear
it's the moment of AHA so as you can see
behind me a work of art a work of art a
sculpture is instantiating a dilemma of
Modern Life a dilemma I think that
anybody everybody can relate to right
there's a great line written by Robert
Moore in the archetype of initiation
when he says if you cannot submit you
cannot die if you cannot die you cannot
be we're all taught this in mythology
classes heed the call become a man
answer the call to adventure overcome
those fears and those boundaries right
transcend evolve become something more
surprise yourself right die into the
moment make the ultimate sacrifice
during these moments of initiation it is
said that we have to surrender we have
to let go right to become one with
everything is to disintegrate
temporarily right to lose your self and
what does that mean to die into the
moment a beautiful metaphor a true poem
if you ask me right to die into the
moment means not to biologically cease
to exist not at all it is an expression
of your vitality in fact to die into the
moment because to die into the moment
actually means to die to who you were
right to die to the fear to die to the
apprehension to die to the self doubting
the self negation to die into the parts
of yourself that are holding you back to
realize that everything you want is on
the other side of fear which is on the
other side of you the only thing
standing in your way it is said is you
and so to witness this etched in stone
right carved into the landscape speaks
meaning right art speaks meaning to
people because the transcendence shines
through the Matis and so here we are
right witnessing a deep fundamental
truth a poetic truth right sometimes
fiction is more truthful than reality
art is the lie that reveals the truth
and so here we are all of us embodied in
that little boy gazing upon the great
unknown
realizing perhaps that this is the final
moment of Absolution when he gets to
become a man if you cannot submit you
cannot die if you cannot die you cannot
be reborn what would you do
you